go to new rules all right yo Rand Paul
either has to lay off the anti-gay
rhetoric or stop standing like this you
were I'm glad that cities are finally
taking the bicycle seriously and
creating special lanes for cyclists but
they have to make them look a little
less like crime scenes I want to see
where I'm supposed to ride not what my
truck outline is gonna look like after I
get flattened by a texting teen in a
Ford Focus normal now that the
Republicans have returned to run the
show in Congress Wall Street bankers
have to start wearing the [ __ ] shirt
again and when they do they also must
immediately bring back cigar bars credit
default swaps and not telling your date
you of herpes knurled Joe Biden has to
admit that this is not what he signed up
for
it's humiliating to be dismissed as some
ridiculous comical character but then to
have to put on the bunny suit oh no new
rule Apple must admit that if the iWatch
meticulously measures heart rate and
motion to log your exercise it's going
to be giving credit for marathon runs to
lots of fat guys who are just jerking
off new rule now that Chinese pandas
Lulu and Lulu ng may have set the world
record for panda sex endurance at 18
minutes three seconds they have to tell
us their secret I mean besides the fact
that it's hard to get off while this
guy's watching
you